[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonjour à tous bienvenue d'ancient
parler sport l'émission phare sur le
sport local dans les yvelines vous
connaissez désormais le concept de
l'émission il y aura comme d'habitude
des analyses des débats et des duel
d'anthologie entre nos incroyables
chroniqueur aujourd'hui ils sont cinq
autour de la table comme le niveau de la
seine en ce moment en région parisienne
et l'homo niveau monte à chaque émission
ils sont affûté comme jamais
présentation en musique on commence à ma
droite c'est son premier est sauf et
sports de 2018 comme toujours il va
donner le meilleur de lui même c'est un
véritable compétiteur champion d'europe
de cyclisme sur piste master soumi
champion du monde n'a plus rien à
prouver le capitaine yann dujarrier est
avec nous pendant une heure sans mittal
vous n'avez pas approuvés y'a rien à
prouver pourra toujours à prouver jamais
rien n'est gagné et même quand on est
devenu une première fois champion est
bien le plus difficile d'y rester
quand on est titré quand on est titré le
plus difficile c'est d'y rester actif de
champion du monde également à suivre
toujours pas émarger sur paille d'or
justement vous allez continuer on
repasse à ma gauche on passe à ma gauche
musique son come back dans cette
émission était je suis attendu d'eux
que celui de michael jordan aux chicago
bulls en 1995 on le surnomme sur ce
plateau le vengeur masqué car c'est un
cavalier international
et oui on a beaucoup d'imagination dans
les soap escorte les a manquées il vous
a manqué raul
outre l autre est avec nous pour cette
émission bonjour à oudon michael par
jour à tous comment expliquez vous cette
longue absence dans cette émission à des
mises au prendre n'a reçu plein de
lettres de femmes nous demandons la
raison savais pas quoi leur répondre
mais bon je fais mon retour j'ai j'avais
plein de projets à mettre en place mais
je suis très content de vous revoir
jouer l'ensemble de l'équipe voilà on va
voir ça dans l'émission si vous êtes
affûté repasse de l'autre côté à musique
lui aussi est en passe de devenir un all
star de cette édition
arrivé en octobre sur ce plateau sur la
pointe des pieds devient aujourd'hui un
titulaire indiscutable ces analyses sont
aussi tranchante qu'une lame s'est
répartie cinglante
tout cela avec un grand self contrôle
nous avons décidé de lui donner un
surnom le à gladiateurs sont longs et
donc pierre chevalier du rugby-club de
versailles comment allez-vous pierre ça
va très bien bonjour à tous force et
honneur force et honneur effectivement
se surnommant ils vous convient bien à
j'aime beaucoup
vous allez bouger l'âge et la barbe de
russell crowe tout va bien c'est un
signe brève comparaison là je prends la
représentation et les flagrantes
effectivement aller je prends aussi on
passe à ma gauche musique son style est
souvent imité mais jamais égalé à chaque
émission il arrivait beaucoup du mois et
son accent du sud-ouest et il arrive à
nous surprendre avec ses punchlines sur
le sport local mesdames et messieurs je
pense je serai que vous passerez une
bonne heure en notre compagnie avec
joris l'ancien coach de plaisir bonjour
jean bonne soirée michael vos soir à
tous voilà une nouvelle émission pour
vous impeccable à un pic à toujours bien
ici toujours revenir au dessus mais on
est vraiment mal
c'est entouré de gladiateurs de
cavaliers
de capital va nous arriver il peut rien
vous arriver on repasse de l'autre côté
musique c'est un véritable cerveau c'est
le cerveau de cette émission ses
capacités vont au delà des bus des plus
grande étude jamais réalisée par l'homme
c'est le albert einstein du sport local
le newton des analyses
c'est une chance pour nous d'avoir une
nouvelle fois sur ce bateau frederick
henderson est avec nous bonsoir tout le
monde s'entraide avec alors comment
allez vous et bien voilà bien que joe
content de retrouver les copains parce
que vous avez pris quelques notes pour
cette émission c'est nous les nerfs des
notes parfois écrits parfois dans votre
tête
j'apprends tout par coeur avant de venir
tous par coeur avant de venir toujours
toutes les semaines tous tes de seine on
va passer maintenant au programme
d'émission aujourd'hui à nous allons
parler de rugby le sky a failli faire
sensation en faisant tomber le leader de
division honneur s'est défaite est-elle
un mal pour un bien nous y répondrons
dans quelques instants nous évoquerons
également le premier match de la saison
des templiers d'elancourt en deuxième
division de football américain mais
avant de développer à ces thèmes coup de
projecteur sur la boxe
[Applaudissements]
on commence donc par de la boxe les
images ont fait le tour des médias
français et internationaux à l'issue de
la victoire par ko au septième rang de
marvin petit face à servir qasmi dans le
championnat international léger une
bagarre générale a éclaté entre les
supporters des deux hommes
ce samedi 20 janvier à levallois perret
les boxeurs élan courtois a même reçu
une chaise sur la tête conséquence le
résultat de marvin petit et non
homologuée à la fin de la rencontre on
pouvait craindre une suspension de la
boxe à vie pour le boxeur on écoute son
entraîneur il vous l'avions eu au
téléphone juste après son combat
je suis dégoûté après on ne sait pas où
on est en train de discuter avec le
promoteur qui a perdu gros
ça représentait mois d'efforts des
années parce que marvin ingelec puis
l'alto qu'avant apprend tout l'avant
donc voilà c'est des années des efforts
pour avoir le poignet de la décision est
finalement tombée ce mercredi 24 janvier
et l'histoire se termine plutôt bien
pour marvin petit il remporte
officiellement la ceinture et intègre le
top 15 mondial il a tenu à réagir sur
les réseaux sociaux on regarde un
extrait en vidéo
la boxe de toute façon c'est un sport
c'est pas assez pas la bagarre on doit
donner l'exemple
c'est vrai ce qui arrive et non du pas
arrivé mais il ya eu beaucoup de trucs à
fait que réveiller ma femme qui était en
salle qui en savent quoi et qui est en
bas on bat du ring et quand vous voyez
votre femme qui est enceinte qui on bat
du ring qui prend une chaise
c'est tout à fait normal qu'on veut
descendre du ring c'est c'était
impressionnant pour moi pour moi après
je je me connais et j'ai vu c'était
j'étais un autre homme en fait il y
avait mes parents ma mère mon neveu il
s'était c'était incroyable non
franchement c'était c'était incroyable
après voilà c'est ça s'est passé comme
ça s'est passé et je remercie voilà j'ai
remercié la fédération je remercie la wb
a d'avoir reconnu aussi merci à doubler
bea
et voilà bien je sais plus quoi vous
dire je suis je suis vraiment très très
heureux d'avoir d'avoir reconnu c'est
cette nature là c'est ma ceinture et six
mois le chanteur doublé via continental
une réaction rapidement autour de cette
table sur cette vidéo
yann trouve dommage qu'il n'ait pas
réussi à contenir ses nerfs malgré
malgré des circonstances en effet comme
il dit doivent montrer l'exemple
maintenant ben voilà oued et d'aider des
excités qui sont pas capables de
comprendre ce que cela différence entre
entre le sport et et puis enfin aurait
certainement que le sport ça doit rester
du sport et l'agressivité ne doit pas
rentrer dans les dents les dents les
terrains dans les terrains dans les
stades tout simplement
pareil pour moi je suis très content que
justice ait été rendue
saleh sur un ring on souffre
physiquement certes mais
psychologiquement et on le remarque et
ça c'est unanime chez tous les boxeurs
11 après un combat on se retrouve dans
un état psychologique qui est très très
fragile et à ce moment là c'est pour ça
que vous voyez jamais vraiment les
boxeurs aller célébrer le leur victoire
lors des fêtes en boîte de nuit où ils
ont surtout besoin d'être entourés de
leurs proches des gens qui leur sont
chers donc on est dans un état
psychologique très fragile et qui peut
pousser à certaines réactions
d'autant plus que on peut c'est pas mon
rôle de le faire là mais on peut
clairement identifier des responsables
et les gens qui ont subi c'est le fan
club de marvin je le connais je le vois
à l'entraînement et on le voit pendant
plusieurs réunions de boxe ces gens qui
font du bruit mais ces gens qui viennent
supporter qu'ils ont qui n'ont jamais
été à l'origine d'un problème quelconque
donc là on s'est vraiment identifié les
coupables et façon marvin va se bonifier
avec l'âge et il apprendra peut-être
mais les boxers en france sont pas comme
un an aux états unis des stars à qui on
apprend à devenir populaire et qui ont
fait une éducation médiatique donc il a
réagi comme il pouvait
et
il se bonifiera lundi dans sa lutte dans
la vidéo il y avait sa femme également
cac a su me dis qu'est-ce que sa femme
enceinte je peux dire déontologiquement
on doit jamais excusé ce genre de
d'action mais moi j'étais désolé je suis
obligé de prendre sa défense à ce moment
là parce que je partage sa salle mais
parce que je me mets à sa place et et on
reste des humains et voilà et je pense
que il n'a fait que réagir à une
animosité qui n'était pas à l'origine de
son origine et de l'origine de son corps
et du coup son titre pleinement valable
à le sauver maxime hérité en plus et on
verra pour la suite
il est dans la joue justement il est
prêt maintenant pour se mettre à la
portée d'un titre mondial même s'il a la
catégorie à très relevé c'est pile le
bon moment il était hors de question que
ça lui passe sous l'ère pierre il ya
deux choses qui me il ya deux choses qui
marquent la première on se rappelle du
titre de cette émission là si on parlait
sport c'est dommage de voir des images
comme celles-là sait bien quelles que
soient les raisons il effectivement
d'aller chercher les responsables de ce
genre de déviance et dérapages donc
c'est vraiment dommage de voir à devoir
une réunion sportive quelle qu'elle soit
tourné au pugilat sur ce point là même
ce même dans une salle de boxe ça doit
donc c'est sur le ring pas ou de repas
autour et la deuxième c'est le mea culpa
du du champion l'acquis qui a réagi à
priori avec ses tripes et avec ses avec
ses nerfs et qui n'a pas mesuré sûrement
les conséquences possibles de se battre
en dehors d'un green day
était humain avant d'être boxeur qui
sait ce qu'il a dit en citant l'ensemble
de sa famille et autres au final bon il
a son titre tant mieux pour lui
il faut vite passer à autre chose sur un
événement comme celui là parce que c'est
pas forcément une très bonne pub pour la
boxe ou pour le sport en général
élémentaires en défaveur de la boxe déjà
calé ça se passe pas très bien en france
la boxe m'a malheureusement je trouve ce
que je trouve dommage c'est que ont dû
prendre prive de la célébration qu'il
aurait dû avoir sur son riz puisque
derrière ben ils accueillent la remise
de la ceinture il a passé comme si donc
tu es champion olympique et tu ne passes
un peu de mou comme celle là tant par la
poste
super maman super ça fait ça fait
plaisir
[Musique]
après moi je veux un petit bémol certes
il a réagi à un humain on est tous
d'accord autour de la table maintenant
c'est quand même professionnel lui de la
boxe et son rôle comme l'a dit pierre
c'est de se battre sur le ring mais en
aucun cas d'aller se battre
de l'autre côté du ring même si on peut
tous autour de la table estimé que c'est
simplement un réflexe humain de voir sa
famille l'a expliqué mais ç'a failli
qu'amélie côté sa carrière
ce débordement de la part d'une cellule
pour moi une faute professionnelle
quelque part il aurait pu être exclu
aurait pu être exclu et se mettre un
terme à sa carrière
les instances voilà mettre un terme à sa
carrière 2 c'est quand même certes c'est
une réaction mais on peut moins l'excusé
que une personne lambda qui normalement
lui c'est un professionnel
il doit maîtriser il dort il doit se
maîtriser quelles que soient les raisons
et je pense qu'il a quand même bien sûr
que moi je suis tout à fait d'accord
c'est normal qu'il a sentie trahie là il
a acquis sur le même terrain il apparaît
agi en professionnel après hélas a
failli lui coûter sa carrière
je pense qu'il en a pris conscience
après coup donc j'espère au moins que ça
lui servira de leçon pour la suite
après bien sûr c'est inexcusable ce qui
se pressent ce type d'événement arrive
heureusement très très peu
dans l'est cette ampleur-là revoilà sont
très souvent le malheureusement le
théâtre d'un conflit qui est bien en
dehors du sport d'un conflit social d'un
conflit entre bandes parfois même de
religion c'est vraiment l'événement qui
s'écartent le plus du sport il ya le
foot aussi mais il ya quand même une
grande partie de foot eux qui vont voir
le foot en boxe non il n'y a pas
beaucoup d'amoureux de boxe et les gens
qui auraient voulu être boxeur qui le
sont pas et ça ça frustre et du coup on
vient voir la violence en france quand
on va voir un combat de boxe on est très
peu a aimé la boxe et ont fini par
préférer la regarder à la télé parce que
comme ça on à son moment de sport à soi
on est pas on n'est pas dérangé par des
gens qui viennent de perdre de manière
pervers voire de la violence c'est
surtout de savoir ça ressemble aussi
malheureusement ça un élastique qui
pètent pas l'intention intention d'avoir
des ballons et autres droite face à face
pas la télé parce que ça n'arrive pas
mais même au vélodrome ça les gens se
sont contenues mais c'est une tension
qui est permanente on a beaucoup de mal
et avec un service de sécurité qui est
qui laisse à désirer par rapport aux
autres sports parce que peu de moyens
donc c'est pour ça qu'on en arrive là on
a on en arrive à l'un des éléments comme
ça puisque normalement oui un match de
foot une bande comme ça puis s'est cassé
la cheville calme et pourquoi marc bini
soit du ring parce que justement les
mecs qui étaient là n'hésitez pas en
mesure de calmer la situation donc ainsi
perdre sa femme c'est parce
qu'effectivement c'est pas du cinéma
c'est parce que vraiment les gens
pourraient pas contenir la masse avec
anderson il a reçu les crachats
notamment en arrivant devant le ring
pour combattre de la part des supporters
de samir kasmi est-ce qu'on comprenait
cette situation ce qui s'est passé après
enfin c'est complètement désolant de
voir ce type de spectacle après j'espère
que ça servira de leçon aux
organisateurs et que toutes les mesures
seront mises en place pour pas que ça se
reproduise et qu'au final on retiendra
de ce combat le titre du boxeur et qu'on
retiendra le sport au delà des la
violence qui a pu avoir à côté
un de plus que malamine koné a déjà
annoncé qu'ils voulaient poursuivre
l'organisation de grands événements
autour de la boxe s'il est si l'offre le
village dans une cavité d'organisation à
des accords et pourquoi pas mais c'est
pas censé se passer comme ça ça reste du
sport qu'on aille comme ça a déjà écrit
autour de la table non je pense que ce
genre de comportement n'a rien à faire
dans le milieu sportif et c'est
important de dénoncer le combattre et et
d'en tirer les leçons à chaque fois
qu'il ya un dérapage de pouvoir faire en
sorte que ça ne se reproduise plus la
question sur ce thème cet incident un
petit suivre marvin petit tout au long
de sa carrière
oui ou non non non oui un petit duel
entre vous pierre et jean genre vous
commencez à vous ça le suivra pas tout
au long de sa carrière
non c'est le suivant pas parce que c'est
vraiment indépendants de sa volonté déjà
et que je pense pas qu'il aura à faire
systématiquement à des gens qui n'ont
rien à faire dans une salle de sport
c'est quand même heureusement pour tout
le monde
un cas isolé ce genre de comportement
est là la fédération elle même a reconnu
quand même que sportivement
sportivement il a quand même sa ceinture
et qu'il continue sa carrière comme si
elle pas eu d'incident donc je peux je
parle du côté sportif
donc pour moi sportivement il peut pas
dire se consacrer à sa carrière et
obtenir
une chance pour le titre champion du
monde auxerre l'étranger ce dont il a
besoin a été de boxer en france moi le
jazz et je dirais simplement que ça ça
peut le suivre parce qu'ils seraient
parle encore au conditionnel serait un
peu plus surveillés sans parler des
circonstances avec la tension le les
circonstances particulières de la boxe
d'un combat de boxe tu disais tout à
l'heure que il faut se rappeler que
c'est un professionnel du métier donc
lui en gros il est issu et qu'il est sur
le ring c'est lui qui combat autour ce
qui se passe ça a dépassé certaines
certaines limites
il a eu cette réaction humaine de ne pas
pouvoir de ne pas devoir peut-être se
maîtriser parce que parce qu'il y avait
ses proches ses proches en danger donc
circonstances un peu particulières
certes mais ça peut ça peut peut-être le
suivre sur sur une surveillance ou en
dix ans il a été capable de le faire une
fois après maintenant ce que ce qu'on
souhaite c'est qu'il redevienne
professionnel et que 1,2 de pareilles
circonstances ne se reproduise pas et de
outil puisse continuer à combattre
uniquement sur le ring épandeur il ya du
gériez un avis qui acquiert raison qui a
tort
marvin à 23 victoires un nul et une
défaite depuis le début de sa carrière
professionnelle
est ce que finalement c'est les chiffres
qu'on va retenir
à la fin de sa carrière et non pas cet
acte là s'il a encore beaucoup de
combats derrière bien sûr ce sera oublié
puisqu'il sera capable de prouver qu'ils
se sentent cette situation ne se
reproduira pas mais justement il est
capable de se contenir
en fin de combat et de pouvoir donc
voilà c'est un cetain
un événement malheureux mais mais ça
avance pas majeur dans une carrière à
majeur des fins
je parlais de football mais c'est vrai
que dans le foot c'est des choses qui
sont déjà arrivés et c'est parce qu'on
retient des clubs on retient pas que ces
éléments là on va plutôt entretenir une
victoire plutôt que plutôt qu'un
un quinqua fait qui a pu se passer voilà
on parle toujours du palmarès est en
effet vous avez raison ce seront
certainement les chiffres qui resteront
sur sa carrière quand il aura terminé
c'était cet événement malheureux ne
restera démarcation penser que ça peut
le rendre plus fort marvin d'avoir vécu
cet épisode là je pense que de doutes
qu'il a eu même si elle a été assez
courte
il a dû se rendre compte à quel point
cette ceinture lui était cher est le
fait de pas avoir été récompensés tout
directement de son chaos
je crois que oui oui ils risquent de
réfléchir à deux fois maintenant à voir
mais gagne en maturité
oui oui certainement mais ça sent ça se
voit mais il va être obligé à faire des
commerçants est d'accord on va lire une
expérience et maturité
ac c'est toujours des événements
compliqué comme ça ça marque une
carrière et c'est vrai que c'est
toujours l'opportunité d'apprendre à
presque important de se rappeler aussi
c'est qu'il a été victime des événements
ne s'est pas lui l'instigateur il ne
faudrait pas non plus le placer en
coupable de la situation il a subi les
événements il a essayé de protéger sa
famille je pense que tout le monde peut
comprendre cette réaction là après c'est
sûr que ça n'a pas sa place à autour
d'un ring ou dans n'importe quelle
enceinte sportive
mais on peut pas trop savoir comment les
gens vont réagir ce qu'ils vont se
souvenir du du combat ou pas enfin
comment ils vont s'en souvenir est ce
que ça restera anecdotique ou est-ce que
ça va le marquer mais je pense que la
mesure où là où sa carrière va continuer
s'ils continuent d'enchaîner les succès
je pense que ça restera que qu'un
mauvais souvenir
une mauvaise période du
dos à karachi dans le trou marvin petit
en route vers un possible titre de
champion du monde mais avant de viser le
monde
il devrait défendre son titre de l'union
européenne au mois de mars après la boxe
du rugby n'a manqué qu'une minute au sky
rugby ce dimanche le 21 janvier pour
créer l'une des plus grosses sensations
de la saison en division honneur le
promu saint quentinois s'est incliné sur
la dernière action du match contre cergy
pontoise après avoir été mené à 12 à 0
le sky marque un essai et deux pénalités
pour passer devant à une minute de la
fin avant de se prendre un contre sur la
dernière action
score final 17 à 13 un scénario qui
laisse beaucoup de regrets de regret au
club on écoute on était presque à à une
seconde quoi il sert et reprennent
l'avantagé avec un essai rage
ah ouais bah plaquages ratés c'est parti
cergy c'est la grosse équipe de la poule
premier quasiment invaincu
jamais vraiment mis en difficulté par
les équipes donc donc c'était une grosse
performance de notre part et c'est très
très frustrant encore de retrouver à
perdre ce match avec ce résultat les
saint quentinois prennent le point de
bonus défensif ils occupent désormais la
8e place du championnat
la question sur ce thème est ce que les
défaites encourageantes existe dans le
sport oui ou non quand on voit le
scénario du match c'est quand même
plutôt encourageant est-ce que les
défaites
alors non on va faire un petit duel non
non non pas devant votre question la
crise la réponse est oui en fait avant
avant de faire un petit duel entre raul
et après l'accord des ressorts on vous
écoute yann par rapport à vos questions
la réponse c'est oui l'été on apprend
dans les faits cette défaite là n'est
pas du tout bon pascal y ait de la fin
vous prenez à courtrai vous avez vous
perdez le match c'est c'la c'est
l'égalisation au football à dans la
dernière minute comme vous ai trouvé de
l'embauché reboucher le champagne et
puis au final vous perdez aux tirs au
but on peut dénoncer ces noms là cette
défaite là elle est vraiment elle est
vraiment et pas encourageantes non pas
du pain pour moi non pas du tout avec
difficile à encaisser du service à huy
petit duel
je commence avec est ce qu'il ya des
défaites encourageantes
ça dépend du contexte je pense dans le
cadre d'un championnat quand le
championnat est encore long si on a
réussi à montrer un fond de jeu plus
intéressant si on a réussi à développer
plus de rubis que le match d'avant ça
reste prometteur pour les matches à
venir impressionné en fin de championnat
ça peut ça peut nourrir des regrets si
on est en début championnat sap est
encourageant parfois parfois ça peut
être ça peut être une bonne défaite
comme mon con comme on dit souvent après
la norme il ya deux championnats
après ça dépend on verra la fin à la fin
du championnat est ce que ils vont
regretter d'avoir laissé quelques points
sur carreau si jamais ils sont relégués
à la fin du championnat
s'il avait pu espérer
décrocher une place pour les play-offs
où on chante au banc ou pour la montée
après six ils ont tous les cas ils
finissent en milieu de tableau ça n'aura
rien changé sera pas eu d'impact sur le
sur le championnat donc ça peut être me
de ca peut être négatif ça peut être
petite fille ça dépend ce que les
enfants après raul
donc c'est ça il existe des défaites
encourageantes sombre moi c'est vrai que
également la défaite c'est pas forcément
eu une quelque chose que j'envisage dans
ce que j'entreprends après pour moi ya
la défaite positive et la défaite
négatif
une défaite pendant laquelle meilleur
niveau s'est illustré et justement par
le fait d'avoir remonté d'avoir parce
qu'ils sont menés quand même 12 à 0 au
début de remontée et de de passer
finalement 2 à 12
voilà et de reperdre par la malchance
bon c'est c'est une défaite durant
laquelle on a perdu d'accord mais on
peut se rassurer sur le fait d'avoir un
d'avoir montré un très très bon niveau
de jeu donc à ce moment là je pense
qu'elle reste quand même positif cette
défaite tiers bonne manière il y aurait
vraiment un seul point qui serait pour
moi encourageant parce que je ne pense
pas qu'il puisse y avoir de défaite
encourageante c'est la manière avec
laquelle ils ont ils ont résisté à un
leader cergy qui arrive avec neuf
victoires une défaite grosse équipe ils
sont ils sont à la maison saint quentin
et à la maison le scénario est juste
dans thèse qui perdent à la dernière
seconde je pense pas qu'ils puissent que
puisse dire que c'est une défaite
encourageante parce que c'est de la
manière dont on se projette dans
l'avenir il est encourageante si jamais
ça montre quelques quelques quelques
qualités mentales qui se révèle quelques
qualités collectives solidaire qui se
révèle pour la fin de la saison
là en l'occurrence on est sur un
scénario où on perd à la dernière
seconde sur un sur un sur un contre je
pense qu'ils vont plus passer les
expressions et ou plus les se découper
esseulé coupé ce les cuisines et puis ce
l'émaillage et après parce que justement
ce type d'ondés passé tellement près que
ce type ce type de scénario et de
conclusion de scénario enfin les vallées
en ôter un petit peu donc je dirais
presque à la place de l'entraîneur je
les encourage peut-être plus à gagner ça
sera plus simple
ça sera plus encourageant pour la fin de
la saison un scénario de défaite on
courait de défaite encourageante c'est
vous êtes contre un adversaire plus fort
et vous avez mené tout le match
sauf que ben voilà ça je jouais jamais à
grand chose et puis ben vous prenez un
essai dans l'est dans les damnés fin
voilà à la fin parce que physiquement
vous avez vous avez baissé et que la loi
c'est à dire que là le scénario il est
vrai pas du tout scénario là il est
vraiment
vraiment rim genre oui alors pour moi et
ça peut être un peu timoré peut-être la
performance du sky rugby avec la météo
aura l'arrêter les visiteurs n'ont pas
pris en compte
c'est dimanche à nankin épouvantable
épouvantable un terrain épouvantable une
position des conditions météo
épouvantables
on sait pertinemment départ qui voudra
également à ce niveau-là ça étrange ils
viennent les équipes ça nivelle les
équipes donc ça favorise les équipes
faibles parce que justement les
conditions climatiques ne permettent pas
de mettre le jeu en place tels que on
peut le faire lorsque le ballon et et
pas d'un très glissant et les choses
comme ça donc
certes ils sont passés près de l'exploit
mais encore une fois ces conditions
climatiques elles les ont les hommes
bien bien bien aidé et là aussi pour moi
oui des fois il ya quelquefois il peut y
avoir des défaites encourageantes
parce qu'il y à ce qu'on appelle rugby
pendant tous les sports des niveaux vous
avez vous êtes tous tombés contre une
équipe où vous allez jouer 10 fois vous
gagnerez 0 fois parce qu'ils sont plus
forts que vous tout simplement
et donc il faut regarder par rapport au
niveau de l'équipe qu'on a en face si
nous on est capable d'élever notre
niveau de jeu et si ce qu'on met en
place à l'entraînement en tant
qu'entraîneur de rugby si le collectif
qui est mis en place fonctionne face à
des grosses équipes mais qu'à l'arrivée
le score n'y est pas ça peut être une
ville une victoire une défaite
encourageante mais sinon dans le monde
et fait qu'il ya des fêtes donc
forcément c'est le seul encouragements
de qu'on peut avoir c'est là compte tenu
du travail fourni sur le terrain et non
pas le résultat
la dalle chocolat oui j'ai revu les
images et une fille qu'on ne peut ne pas
feindre peut féliciter c'est le
caméraman on n'est même pas foutu
d'avoir laissé laisser victorieux
c'était moi je l'assumé
alors en fin d'année qu'est-ce que les
coaches peuvent travailler quand même
autour de cette performance
si je peux appeler ça une performance
c'est compliqué j'ai pas tous les
tenants et les aboutissants si je peux
ramener ça à ce que moi j'ai pu vivre en
tant qu' en tant que joueur tu es ya
quelques années quand on avait joué en
autriche en championnat d'europe
on avait rencontré une grosse équipe
européenne et puis on avait perdu de pas
grand chose on avait perdu 14,6 à la fin
du match et c'est vrai que ben n'aurait
pu croire que ben n'aurait pas fait le
point on aurait pris une caisse si on
serait rentrés chez nous on aurait fait
36 heures de bus aller-retour points
mais c'est vrai qu'on est venu
d'autriche avec des blessures et que
derrière on avait une demi finale de
championnat de france à jouer et on est
venu avec tellement de blessés que une
équipe qu'on avait malmené en
championnat au match aller bon match
retour on n'a pas réussi à les vaincre
et ça nous a coûté notre saison ça il
des fêtes cavell est encourageante au
final nous a coûté bien plus cher que ce
qu'on aurait voulu donc c'est toujours
une histoire de contexte et comment
réagit les jeux comment réagissent les
joueurs comment agissent groupe à ce que
le groupe a souffert à l'issue du match
ou pas c'est vrai qu'au delà du résultat
c'est plus aussi la manière comme ça a
déjà été dit qu'il permet de décider ou
non si le la défaite a été encourageante
ou pas bien la question sur cette
thématique on va regarder classement ils
sont pour l'instant 8e sur 10 équipes
est ce qu'ils peuvent se sauver il ya qu
un seul que nous sommes l'équipe qui
descend alors c'est moi qui posais ils
ont 10 points d'avancé sur la chasse
galerie dit ça va quoi on a déjà passé
vous n'avez déjà passé c'est la même
chose dans l'autre
dans la poule dans la poule de niveau
passé on restait en danger
je ne me poserai s'il reste sept matches
vous d'accord ça voudrait dire qu'il
faudrait que brétigny gagné trois
matches le plus que le sky regardez à
tous les niveaux même même en tant qu'un
tout en quinze de france les défaites
encourageantes avec son aplomb d'un
certain moment
c'est pas gagné le mot de la fin sur ce
thème
après le rugby nous allons passer à un
autre sport de contact le football
américain de frederick henderson dans la
peau d'une américains les templiers
d'elancourt reprenez ce week-end le
championnat de deuxième division pour
leur premier match les landes pourtant
n'ont pu faire mieux que match nul à 8
partout sur le terrain contre les
vikings de villeneuve d'ascq dont les
conditions climatiques compliquées
favori de la rencontre les templiers
réalise une première contre performance
cette saison on écoute la réaction d'un
joueur à la fin du marche on s'attendait
pas à ce résultat là il sera qu'on
s'attendait à mener très rapidement dans
la gamme c'est vrai que comme je vous ai
dit auparavant on a fait pas mal
d'erreurs en défense et en attaque ce
qui nous a mis en difficulté à suivre le
score c'est une vraie déception ce
résultat après l'accord personnes
forcément nous on est là pour gagner que
par moment la victoire n'est pas au
rendez vous forcément énormément de
déception
presque autant qu'il des fêtes et le
problème du match nul c'est qu'on sait
pas trop comment
comment la considérer s'est passé une
déception c'est pas aussi pire qu'une
défaite mais c'était à c'était c'est un
premier match de saison après on pensait
le gagner les résultats sont pas sont
pas au rendez vous on a fait trop
d'erreurs on n'a pas été capable de
faire la différence au moment crucial la
météo aussi était difficile mais a été
difficile pour les deux équipes donc
c'est pas vraiment une excuse je veux
dire la météo nous a aussi sauvé le
match parce qu'il faut voir aussi que
l'équipe d'en face était aussi capable
match nul 8-8 aurait pu nous la mettre à
la fin c'était
ça passe c'est compliqué après c'est un
premier match de saison donc un
championnat c'est long et pourrait
reconduire agissent déjà dès ce week-end
on est retourné au boulot cette semaine
on appelait on en a pris les vidéos on a
décortiqué
j'ai noté g noter les joueurs sur leur
performance et beaucoup de zéros j'ai eu
beaucoup d'erreurs qui va falloir
corriger des prochains matchs qui sera
un âge contre le promu donc on peut
espérer pas dire un match facile mais
pas forcément un match aussi compliqué
contre les cadors du championnat donc
difficile un match nul c'est un peu nul
quoi alors pour ce premier match de la
saison les tempes ils n'ont pas joué
avec d'import us je me trompe pas faire
les personnes donc des joueurs venus à
des états unis quand on voit le résultat
final est ce qu'on se dit qu'il ya
urgence à recruter un américain c'est la
question de cette thématique foot us oui
ou non est ce qu'il y a urgence à
recruter un import us viennent partager
partager
enfin petit duel entre vous raul et
pierre leur tour ils vont commencer je
pense que c'est une bonne idée je suis
favorable à ce genre de de remaniement
dans ces sports qui sont beaucoup plus
américain de rire d'origine et met à nu
ajoutant une seule limite c'est que ces
choses-là reste provisoire et que les
laisser intervenants américains et un
rôle et une deuxième casquette de
formateur au sein du club français ou
européens tous les cas dans lequel il
intervient ce que je pense que ce qui
est ce qui rend le projet intéressant à
la fin ces deux capables de constituer
une équipe
100% française qui qui jouent au
meilleur niveau à condition que cela
soit provisoire et que les gens qui
viennent jouer ne viennent pas juste
jouer et
l'encaissé le pognon mais aussi former
formait des français je sais pas trop
comment ça s'organise mais c'est pour
moi c'est la meilleure répondre et
approuvé avec commerces et chemins
parallèles par rapport au basket nous
taire les deux sports us phares qui sont
qui sont importés en europe et notamment
en france
je connais pas la qualité ton de ton
effectif aller en cours
mais il me semble qu'un apport d'un
joueur ou d'un ou deux techniciens
américains pourraient transmettre au
mans la culture transmettent acculturés
et faire un petit peu ce déclic en début
de saison qui pourrait apporter un plus
et un peu de bleu un peu plus de force
peut-être un peu plus de sérénité par
l'expérience à une équipe qui démarre
son championnat
est ce que c est ce que ça doit durer
toute la saison
ça dépend de la manière dont la
mayonnaise prend mais en tout cas je
pense que c'est ça lutter en terme de en
termes de transmission de culture
d'expérience et puis de sérénité
peut-être de sécurité de sérénité que ça
apporte à une à une équipe qui démarre
qui démarre sa saison
fredrik andersson concernant les impôts
bas c'est un peu comme disait raul si
c'est juste pour prendre un mercenaire
qui vient qui saura clipon ce caillou
qui s'en va on sait pas c'est pas
forcément intéressant donc généralement
il reste quand même temps au club
ça dépend des américains d'aller pour
aller poursuivre l'élan de gaillou
généralement ils arrivent ils arrivent
en début de saison autour du mois de
janvier et puis va jusqu'à la fin du
championnat
après ça dépend des besoins de l'équipe
ça dépend de du projet aussi qu'on a
qu'on qu'on lui proposait ça oriente
aussi notre cherche plus à vis de visage
mais c'est vrai que c'est plus
intéressant par dans un sport comme le
basket on prend un américain ben ça se
joue à cinq contre cinq c'est déjà 20 %
de l'effectif sur une équipe de football
américain c'est un jazz sport de
spécialistes y en a onze en attaque
c'est pas l'aimer c'est pas les mêmes
onze en défense et dire que si je prends
un américain ça va me faire ça à faire
un 11e je sais pas combien ça fait au
pourcentage mais
et forcément son impact sur le jeu feu
bon je ne pas être aussi jour que dans
d'autres sports après moi je pars du
principe qu'on peut avoir le meilleur
américain du monde si autour l'effectif
de français n'est pas n'a pas le niveau
ça va pas vraiment d'impact va venir
s'en aller il aura rien mais c'est au
club
c'est pour ça qu'au si souvent au niveau
des imports c'est plus intéressant de
retrouver des américains qui peuvent
aussi coaché sur les jeunes qui peuvent
pas ou s'ils vont faire venir des coachs
moscou - les entraîneurs ils viennent et
ils transmettent le bas leur savoir et
quand ils s'en vont - ils restent il
reste ce qu'on a appris lui concéder
joueurs c'est pas toujours le cas c'est
plus compliqué c'est un peu la roulette
russe on sait jamais être sûr qu'on va
tomber dès fois on touche aux américains
ils sont pas bons on aurait mieux fait
de rien prendre du tout de prendre un
canadien vous prendre un bus ou de
prendre un autre joueur ou ne rien
prendre du tig lancent des cailloux et
puis acheter du matos pour autre chose
quoi mais c'est vrai que dans les
imports c'est vrai que ça fait sur les
tous les joueurs veulent tous savoir
qu'est-ce qu'on prend prendre américain
machin vrai que souvent prenez les
quarterbacks parce que c'est des
positions qui sera développé en français
vous aviez pris dans le passé
chen shelton qui a emmené les templiers
en fait d'europe qui avait un sac
sublime eric schaeffer est par contre il
a chaud qui a moins marqué c'est
tellement bonne pioche voilà et il a
emmené le club en deuxième division
dormir
ça n'a pas été une très bonne saison
s'était maintenu à l'issue de la saison
c'est vrai que c'était l'exemple de
l'américain qui pèse pas plus que ça sur
le fait un peu regretté le fait d'avoir
pris un apport qu'on n'ait pas plus
quelqu'un de gentil quand on a
après c'est un super gars donc c'est
toujours c'est que c'est compliqué de
christian gajan la politique de
formation également comme disait raul
je sais plus si on avait utilisé comme
entraîneur mais les américains qu'on
avait pris ces dernières années avec
août chez sur les jeunes c'est vrai que
les jeunes étaient super heureux d'avoir
un coût de cham et lesquin pour leur
apprendre le football ça augmenter
l'investissement des jeunes c'est vrai
que ça va laisser leur trace a laissé la
trace donc de leur passage donc ça
c'était vraiment intéressant
yann est ce que vous êtes plutôt
favorable restons restons bleu blanc
rouge parce que
je pense qu'on a un discours très
nationaliste moi je suis je suis super
show un peu de souci donc non il assume
j'achète mon chauvinisme maintenance et
voilà c'est vrai que ce sont des sports
culturellement qui viennent de l'autre
côté de la planète donc bah main voilà
ouais donc peut-être faire avec les
français qu'on a ici en france auront
ouais je joue parce que pas simplement
pour la simple et bonne raison c'est
alors il faudrait que tout le monde joue
le jeu aussi mais parce que on joue
entre français mais s'il en est fait
dans d'autres clubs ils ont des
étrangers qui viennent à renforcer il ya
un moment où vous êtes obligés aussi de
de copier sur de copier des copains et
c'est ça c'est une faille tout le monde
joue le jeu que tout le monde reste
franco français et d'avoir peut-être 7,7
de créer ce cette marque de fabrique
comme dans le rugby c'est vrai que
beaucoup de alors ça ne marche pas très
bien ces dernières années et ça commence
à faire un petit peu long mais c'est
vrai qu'on dit que les français ils ont
un jeu un jeu atypique et donc qui ça
peut partir à n'importe quel moment
de n'importe où c'est vrai que c'est ça
qui est fort fort dans le rugby donc
peut-être sur un sport comme le football
américain créé sa propre identité voilà
avec anderson est ce que ça coûte cher
aussi de recruter un américain pour les
finances du club
bah c'est forcément c'est un succès des
ressources après si les ressources qu'on
investit sur un américain cdc ressources
qu'on peut pas investir ailleurs sur du
matériel pour les jeunes sur du matériel
à louer c'est vrai que c'est un sport
pas forcément facile d'accès et par le
coût du initiale de l'équipement et puis
vis-à-vis de vis-à-vis du développement
du club toujours plus intéressant
d'investir ses ressources dans le
matériel ce qui veut dire que sur
l'année +1 plus de plus trois balles et
l'argent est toujours là qu'avec un
apport dans l'ue a donné l'argent et une
à lille après pas l'argent a disparu il
a appuyé le plus vraiment de retour
dessus
après quand on regarde
l'effectif qu'on peut revoir je pense
qu'on a on a de quoi développer un jeu
intéressant sans importe je pense que en
championnat de deuxième division c'est
pas indispensable c'est vrai que ça peut
être un plus mais mais comme je disais
c'est important aussi développer ce
qu'il ya autour de l'import qui peut
arriver je pense que ça moi en tant que
coach ça m'intéresse plus de développer
des joueurs français que parce qu'elle
veut faire venir la numérique 1 qui j'ai
pas grand chose à apprendre qui va faire
son business un peu de son côté donc ça
c'est plus et c'est moins avantageux ses
inconvénients
un dernier mot sur les templiers
d'elancourt georges agostino le
président emblématique du club a décidé
de quitter son poste après 17 ans de
bons et loyaux services et joël da silva
qui reprend la main nous expliquer qu'il
sentait une certaine usure sur son poste
vous le comprenez ferrer comme personne
ah bah après 33 ans passés au club et
puis avec les années qui passent c'est
sûr que c'est et 17 ans à la tête du
club et 17 ans à la tête du club c'est
vrai que il en a vu passer des
américains justement il y en a vu passer
des équipes des saisons beaux et bons et
moins bons
donc c'est vrai que lui et puis c'est
toujours intéressant si un ace on avait
travaillé aussi en amont pour préparer
cette transition on avait tous fait le
bureau et c'est finalement sur le
terrain là le passage de flambeau se
voit beaucoup moins c'est plus tendance
dans l'arrière boutique vis-à-vis des
relations du club peuple peut avoir
vis-à-vis des municipalités et des
partenaires qui sont derrière que ça va
changer mais la claque deux fois et wen
ont cessé une passe et c'est une page
qui se tourne et ça fait ça fait un
petit pincement au coeur
placez la fin de cette machine pièce on
passe maintenant à notre focus du jour
[Applaudissements]
dans notre focus nous avons parlé d'une
vraie force de la nature à 29 ans caddie
baradji réalise en moyenne 25 heures de
sport par semaine et peut soulever
jusqu'à 80 kg des performances qui lui
ont permis de devenir amis fitness
france à créteil en novembre dernier
pour réaliser cet exploit cet ancien
athlète et tenniswomen d'un mètre
soixante huit pour 60 kg a dû remporter
plusieurs épreuves sur une journée elle
était évidemment ravi de cette victoire
en écoute et j'avais vraiment envie de
me dépasser 2 d'arriver au bout et deux
médians j'ai fait tout ce que je pouvais
que je gagne ou pas en fait d'être allé
au bout de moi même dans une compétition
où super pas mon domaine en fait en
parallèle de ces grosses séances de
fitness qu'a dit donne des cours de
pilates de renforcement musculaire et
surtout de zumba cinq fois par semaine
entre voisins boutonnet montigny le
bretonneux une vraie force de la nature
une réaction par rapport à cette fille
hors normes phoniques
c'est très bien c'est très bien ce
qu'elle fait si elle peut inspirer les
gens à faire plus de sport et ses actifs
sains que pour pour la santé même que ce
soit pas dans une optique de compétition
c'est toujours une bonne chose
yann alors moi j'ai découvert le fitness
il n'y a pas très longtemps grâce à
grâce à la chaîne équipe et j'ai été
impressionné par par là
à part l'effort physique c'est vrai que
ça reste des poids qui sont pas
accessibles à tout le monde et en plus
un nombre de répétitions sur sûr
beaucoup d'épreuves qui sont ils sont
vraiment très très costaud alors après
c'était un
l'un championnat du monde qui était
retransmis mais non vraiment j'ai trouvé
cette discipline très complète et je
comprends aussi la raison pour laquelle
ça devient très non énormément de succès
dans les salles
parce que parce que je pense que enfin
voilà vous n'avez pas la pénalité du
delà du côté technique qui dans certains
sports n'est acquis que très jeune et
donc quelqu'un qui était sportif et qui
ans durant dans son sport quand il
arrive sur sur sur le fitness comme
comme celui là plus il ya il peut
vraiment très rapidement prendre prendre
beaucoup de plaisir parce que la
technique s'acquiert rapidement et moi
je me souviens un petit parallèle quand
quand je me suis mis au roller il m'a
fallu plusieurs années pour pouvoir ne
pas être bons techniquement mais pour
pouvoir avoir vraiment faire des progrès
c'est très très très long donc voilà il
ya beaucoup de sport quand on arrive sur
le tard on est on est on est vraiment
pénalisés et ce sport là le permet et et
en plus j'ai eu l'impression qu'ils
avaient pas non plus énormément de
traumatismes physiques y avait juste une
épreuve de course à pied le reste le
reste ça a l'air d'être quand même assez
cool et est très encadrée donc non
vraiment j'ai trouvé ça très intéressant
la question sur ce thème ces
distinctions permet tel d'encourager la
pratique du fitness
oui non oui unanime de genlis
vous avez pris tout de suite votre wii
c'est toujours eu et c'est toujours en
plus simplement de cela
fitness le crossfit c'est un petit peu
les phénomènes de mode et du prêt ça
dure avec un petit peu parce que
j'agisse les phénomènes de mode c'est
que sur le début à cette émission peut
il c'est pour ça je dis et phénomène de
mode mais qui dure comme le crossfit
aussi crossfit on disait on disait ça ça
va passer et ça passe pas ça continue et
ça prend même de l'ampleur et je pense
que ce genre voilà ce genre de résultat
va encourager la pratique de cette
discipline et surtout le nombre le
nombre de pratiquants
parce que forcément en plus c'est
vraiment comme l'a dit jens est vraiment
s'il n'y a pas vraiment véritable
traumatisme
c'est accessible peu à tout le monde
c'est simplement vraiment avoir du temps
à consacrer et de l'énergie c'est pas
évident quand elle est là échelle de
choses
la gamine donc 25,6 par par semaine
c'est là pendant les journées ils nous
voilà donc le dock la pratique la
pratique à la base de toute façon la
pratique du sport et la compétition au
niveau c'est très bon c'est que du bonus
c'est ultra ludique aussi et je vois
j'ai un j'ai un ami qui salle 2
une salle de fitness en salle de muscu
dans le centre de la france et enfin du
côté d'orléans et il a ouvert une
section crossfit bain
elle a été très très rapidement le cours
a été très rapidement complet c'est
vraiment un héros et un vrai phénomène
est un vrai succès wes brown et là votre
avis on remarque que c'est un c'est un
nouvel effet de mode
justement le le fitness le crossfit
faire attention à ce qu'on mange
c'est très présente très présents dans
les réseaux sociaux donc je pense que
c'est surtout ça qui a eu une influence
sur le fait que les salles de sport
n'ont jamais été aussi pleines pas
forcément sur un concurrent parce que
parce que c'est simple on a une
génération pas beaucoup parlé oui c'est
plus le fait que les gens se diffuse
s'identifie à un objectif qui veulent
atteindre plus que cette miss fitness
dont on n'a pas vraiment entendu parler
dans le grand média quoi je pense pas
que ça va changer quelque chose même
s'il ya plein d'autres facteurs qui font
que c'est c'est une branche qui est
volubile tant mieux parce que c'est ça
fait parmi des ça fait partie des rares
choses qui sont à la mode et qui sont
saines
aujourd'hui en général on va entendre en
plus vers quelque chose qui est malsain
pour l'esprit et le corps ça on est là
effectivement c'est évolutif donc temps
mais en pratique c'est le double sens en
fait la pratique est à dire notre petit
arabe
la pratique est pratique c'est à dire
que c'est justement c'est justement
facile rapide de pouvoir lire en salle
et d'y passer le temps qu'on a
effectivement là dessus recevait sur ce
débat là la première la première
nouvelle c'est de savoir qu'il ya un
titre de miss france fitness ja c'est ça
qui tient le mât d'où il fera des quasi
avec le monde du sport n'est pas prête
de se terminer la sportive envisage de
défendre son titre de miss fitness
france l'année prochaine est de
participer à d'autres concours en passe
maintenant à notre rubrique débats
du cyclisme sur piste de notre débat du
jour des revenants ont été retenus avec
l'équipe de france pose manche de coupe
du monde programmée du 19 au 21 janvier
grégory baugé et michael d'almeida qui
s'entraîne depuis quelques semaines au
vélodrome de saint-quentin-en-yvelines
ils avaient la possibilité de relancer
leur carrière en bleu à minsk après
avoir été écarté suite à leur
comportement aux jo de 2016 à rio
grégory baugé n'a finalement pas
participé à cause d'une grippe lors
autour de ces deux légendes du cyclisme
sur piste est déjà à l'étude au mois de
novembre
on écoute le nouveau directeur technique
national de la fft les anciens
évidemment sont toujours membre du pôle
france ils s'entraînent ils font partie
de l'équipe de france donc après une
période un peu tumultueuse qui a été
juste après les jo
tout s'est mis en place on l'a repris
l'entraînement sur de bonnes bases donc
les anciens avec coupure de quelques
mois n'était pas compétitif sur ce
championnat
donc ça nous a permis d'essayer de
des jeunes coin de laisser leur chance
aux jeunes coureurs et là on a vu
voilà on a vraiment vu des bons
résultats leur retour dans les petits
papiers des bleus se fait seulement
quelques semaines après les championnats
du monde avant les championnats en 2008
aux pays-bas à apeldoorn
il se fait dans un contexte où les
jeunes de l'équipe de france brille
quentin lafargue 27 ans sébastien vigier
20 ans mathilde de gros 18 ans benjamin
thomas 22 ans ont tous réalisé de très
bons championnats d'europe en novembre
dernier la question sur ce thème pour
les championnats du monde vous êtes plus
pour la nouvelle génération où
l'ancienne génération
vous n'êtes plus pour la nouvelle
génération sévère en scène génération
c'est rouge de tout sport et de la
génération y en a tout simplement parce
que l'ancienne génération n'a pas
n'a pas de donné l'image que n'a pas
fini sur l'image qu'elle aurait dû avoir
parce que malgré malgré les multiples
titres de championne aux mines qu'ils
ont pu acquérir pendant pendant une
longue période
voilà ça que le fiasco de rio à pèse un
peu dans la danse dans la balance et
donc voilà maintenant on est plutôt
tourné sur sur donc ses jo tokyo et puis
et puis paris 2024 donc c'est les jeunes
qui vont qu'il faut qu'il faut qu'il
faut nourrir et qu'il faut aguerrir pour
pouvoir être compétitif et lors de ses
deux prochaines séances qui sont pour le
cyclisme sur piste en plus des échéances
majeures aujourd'hui
jason kenny on ne l'a pas revu le
britannique champion olympique de double
champion olympique à londres et à rio on
est là toujours pas revenu sur sur le
sur les compétitions
il a et voilà ils continuent sans faille
il a repris l'entraînement mais il est
toujours pas là donc
alors après je vais pas dire que c'est
trop tard pour pour pour grégory ni pour
me tél parce que michael a été le
meilleur finisseur sur la vitesse par
équipes pendant de très longues années
donc c'est encore possible
grigory but est donc oui j'allais
prendre l'exemple de deux soeurs chris
hoy qui qui a été champion olympique de
karine à 35 ans donc pour moi il ya bien
sûr que c'est pas trop tard pour eux
mais c'est vrai que ont ils ont faut
qu'ils redorent leur blason auprès du
grand public pour pouvoir mairie fargues
pour mériter cette place et c'est vrai
qu'aujourd'hui avec les résultats que
les jeunes ont pu donner
dernièrement on a envie de les voir et
on envie de et surtout la sympathie
qu'ils peuvent qui peuvent dégager à
vaincre quentin lafargue est un est un
est un jeune qui est très très gentil
très accessible et est donc voilà on a
envie de envie de les voir et de les
voir performer
maintenant je pense que le problème de
quentin c'est qu'il va certainement être
barrée par un petit jeune qui restent
figées dont vous avez parlé ça leur
chante ans tu as 20 ans était vraiment
très très impressionnant toujours me
rappeler le les palmarès de verrerie
baugé et michael d'almeida grégory baugé
à 32 ans il a remporté quatre titres de
champion du monde de vitesse
individuelle 5 en équipe il a remporté
quatre médailles aux jo mais jamais de
médaille d'or pour le tigre michael
d'almeida lui trente ans deux médailles
olympiques
une médaille d'or acquise en 2015 aux
championnats du monde de saint quentin
en yvelines
ils ont un palmarès comme qui fait rêver
jean c'est vrai c'est vrai ce serait ça
vous fait rêver
ah oui ça me fait rêver mais là non mais
tracté morel ont aussi il avait le
palmarès fabuleux mais place aux jeunes
quoi place aux jeunes parce que c'est
pas avec ses pavés que certes il n'a dit
ils ont eu un très très beau palmarès on
ne peut que les féliciter
maintenant c'est jeudi en 2024 cc paris
du 24 ses compétiteurs là ne seront pas
qu'on n'y seront pas donc il faut quand
même il faut quand même voir un petit
peu plus loin
que les échéances
proches et c'est avec ces jeunes qu'on
me fera une belle équipe et qu'on aura
qu'on ira gratter les titres et puis
peut-être que dans dix ans ces jeunes là
auront le même voire peut-être un
palmarès plus important peut pas être et
avoir ôté donc faut savoir faut savoir
laisser laissé de place je ferais comme
personne finalement celui qui arrive a
le mieux tiré son épingle du jeu c'est
peut-être françois pervis qui apparaît
le même âge que grégory baugé finalement
qui arrive à s'implanter dans cette
équipe de france ce jeune il participe
depuis depuis jo de rio à des épreuves
de coupe du monde et des championnats et
il est champion du monde en titre
également on chez ces hommes après on
n'est pas forcément obligé de poser les
anciens et les nouveaux je pense que il
ya la première échéance avait troqué au
tokyo cédant 2 ans et c'est pas très
loin est ce que ça peut être l'occasion
d'un passage de relais c'est vrai que
les jeunes peuvent toujours profiter des
bas de l'expérience des anciens et c'est
vrai que s'ils peuvent ne pas répliquer
les erreurs de la génération précédente
c'est toujours un bonus surtout si on
voit à long terme et qu'on essaie de
préparer au mieux parler de 1024 parce
que là pour le pousser dans six ans et
c'est vrai que la génération actuelle
ceux qui sont en fin de carrière et
seront plus là donc non je pense qu'il
faut être faut être intelligent dans la
stratégie qu'on adopte sur les
prochaines années à venir essayer de
trouver un équilibre entre l'expérience
et des anciens qui sont toujours
performant et puis des jeunes
prometteurs qui montre déjà des
résultats très satisfaisants
indépendamment de leur âge donc
maintenant le défi ça va être dur et sur
plusieurs olympiades et faire en sorte
que le cyclisme français reste en haut
de la fiche pour de nombreuses années
vous êtes d'accord avec fred et corner
san il faut mixer peut-être cette
génération une nouvelle génération moi
c'est pour des grandes échéances ces
mêmes c'est quasiment une recette pour
moi qui est indispensable parce que je
pense qu'à hélas à 30 ans on sait pas
non plus énormément écarté de son pic de
forme je pense même si le cyclisme j'ai
pas mon domaine
dans quasiment tous les sports à 30 ans
on n'est jamais un ancien sportif n'a
pas beaucoup d'espoir dans lequel on est
vu à 30 ans ensuite par contre on a on a
ce
cette expérience des grosses échéances
passées
et justement il ya quand même un bon
pourcentage de la réussite qui dépend de
l'âge et de la gestion son stress et de
la gestion de son quotidien toujours
tout au sein de l'événement
esaïe avec les anciens qui peuvent nous
l'apprendre je crois que c'est très
important qui est toujours des personnes
qui ont déjà vécu ccg séance pour savoir
comment gérer son énergie ce à quelques
mois et à quel moment il faut mettre la
pression à quelques contrairement à un
jeune qui n'a pas forcément expérience
aux scandales en tout la condition
physique mais qui n'a pas vraiment de
repères émotif dans des événements comme
les jo où les championnats du monde
c'est ce qui se passait dans l'équipe de
france le le flambeau se transmettait un
petit peu d'année en année florian
rousseau parce que l'avantagé d'un
sprinteur c'est avec la carrière est
quand même très longue et dans le
cyclisme les carrières sont donc du coup
ça qu'il ya les nouvelles générations
arrivées mais ils étaient encadrés ils
étaient parlées par les anciens le
problème qu'il ya avec grigoriy michael
c'est vrai que le fait d'avoir terni
leur image
peut-être que les jeunes vont peut-être
être un peu raide science voilà tout à
fait c'est donc là ils ont un gros
travail à faire pour montrer qu'ils sont
capables de le faire et je sais que
michael et michael lorsque j'ai déjà vu
michael donner des conseils sur des
championnats
régionaux qui ou quel ils venaient
participer aux jeunes en leur disant tu
vois sur cette manche la torah dû faire
ceci devrait du personnel ils sont
capables de le faire maintenant voilà
falloir lafleur travailler et montrer
qu'ils qu'ils ont mon envie et qui sont
capables et de redorer 7 cette image on
va parler également des filles à 110
clerc 29 ans qui n'a peut-être pas dit
son dernier mot très grande respect
féminine depuis plusieurs années elle
est partie à tahiti pendant les vacances
pour revenir encore plus forte matinaux
de gros qui est la nouvelle sprinteuse
on peut dire qu'il faille pépite du
cyclisme français aura peut-être besoin
de 210 clair à l'avenir pour pouvoir
grandir encore un peu plus mais
complètement à côté de son est clair que
ça s'appelle faire un beau duo la
problème les deux bah oui bien sûr mais
là pour parce que la problématique de
mathilde c'est que le vélo il ya trois
ans savait pas ce que c'était quoi donc
elle est arrivé vraiment sûr pas sur le
tard mais elle est arrivée par hasard
sur un sur un vélo c++ et cet espoir là
qu'il faut qu'il faut retenir
et donc elle a énormément à apprendre
maintenant elle a des qualités qui sont
incroyable c'est c'est pas assez donné à
très peu de gens mais enfin ouais c'est
unique même je dirais donc elle faisait
du basket ya encore trois ans détenant
un pôle espoir un pôle espoir régional
en basket et suite à des soutes à des
tests sur sur un vélo et bien on sait
ans ils se sont rendus compte que qui
valait mieux qu'elle aie qu'elle aille
faire du vélo et c'est les résultats des
derniers résultats le jeu le jeu
prouvent puisque puisque à peine monté
sur le vélo elle est championne du monde
juniors donc donc c'est énorme
et puis elle a battu tous les records
qu'ils avaient été tous les records
nationaux qui avait établi était et elle
est qu avait été établi par part est
précédé par me présente coureuses
française je vais y arriver je
reprendrai c'est ma respiration et puis
et puis donc maintenant mathilde voilà
arrive aussi avoir de très bons
résultats est là elle a obtenu d'aidé
deuxième temps sur des manches
qualificatives en 200 m sur les coupes
du monde donc donc elle et elle est
vraiment vraiment impressionnante
on voit ses chronos descendre très
rapidement et très régulièrement donc en
cadence a pu aussi de la prestance
vincent duclert 110 claire doit lui
servir et de lui apporter de la delà de
l'expérience en terme de ce que disait
raul pour la halle comment aborder les
compétitions comment aborder les
échéances donc la mathilde avait
rendez-vous aujourd'hui avec son son
chirurgien j'ai pas eu les les résultats
mais normalement donc elle devrait
pouvoir reprendre l'entraînement et même
si elle n'a pas beaucoup par été pouvoir
et donc être compétitive pour les
championnats du monde
maintenant ça va être des choses qui
sont simplement choisir pour prendre de
l'expérience
jean peut-être que vous êtes un peu
comme mathilde mathier d'euros peut-être
éventuellement vous pouvez acheter sur
le nombre non pas sur le non le cyclisme
peut-être que vous êtes très bon en
cyclisme peut-être c'est possible oui
mais j'ai vu le scooter
alors l'annnonce de la section qui se
fera le mardi 6 février les championnats
du monde se dérouleront du 28 février au
4 mars
et voilà ça sera la fin le mot de la fin
sur cette émission il ya du jarrier
désolé de vous avoir coupé c'est la fin
de cette émission sont aux troupes de
george à 8 février pour une nouvelle
émission va terminer par une citation
d'un boxeur professionnel de sugar ray
robinson pour être champion vous devez
croire en vous même quand personne
d'autre ne le fait je vous laisse
à bientôt sur tv 78
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]